what do you think of writers who don't
need to outline to write a great story
well there's so many different
approaches
uh i mean the bottom line is either the
story they're writing works or it
doesn't
if it doesn't work and they don't
outline then it may
be something that they want to add to
their repertoire
if it does work then whatever they've
created as their process
it works if the story if people love the
story then whatever they do works
it's just one approach to
the process of creating developing and
constructing a story
for me it's a deep habit to do that
because
one of the central problems for
scriptwriters
is that dramatic writing is an extremely
stripped down literary form
it demands complete economy
mostly because it's a performance medium
and the only thing that actually
it's like an iceberg where there's a
bunch of
parts of the story that are
you know part of the mechanics of the
story but the part that the audience
actually
sees on stage or on screen
is just a sequence of events that
happens like
the guy walks into the room to
get his valuable thing from out of
hiding
and there's somebody watching from the
window or behind the curtain with a
knife
and it's just a sequence of events where
the person gets the thing out of hiding
then the other person comes out and
tries to take it from them
so it's a highly specific set of
incidents
and there isn't room
for anything else in that particular
scene
and this is called separating the
necessary from the unnecessary
so that the performance
generally won't it won't make it to
performance if it's
bogged down with the unnecessary because
the script doesn't read well
but people will often put
will allow the unnecessary to creep into
the script from all different directions
and the outlining process
the way i use it and the way i train in
it is that
you have to get the big building blocks
of your story
working first because if the
if the major girders and beams if the
big bones of your story
don't work dramatically
then nothing else you add to it is gonna
matter
the details don't matter it's like
some writers will have a beautifully
written scene in a script that doesn't
work
it doesn't amount to anything it's like
having an ornately finished room and a
house that's
falling over you've got gold leaf and
oak and marble and everything else
but the house is literally tipping over
so
if you got to get the big structure
right and that's
the most basic component
of an outline once you get that working
then you layer in a little more detail
so if you have a sequence of events that
constitutes the spine of your story and
those are just
the big building blocks of your story
with no detail
and you link those up and you take a
look at it and go
oh that's better than i thought it would
be or i could see how i thought i had a
problem in act 2 and i can see that
clearly now that i've got the major
building blocks and then you improve on
that
and then look at it again and go yeah
now that works then
you can break that up into acts and
develop a little more detail for act one
so you gradually layer in a little more
detail as it becomes necessary
but layering on only that which is
necessary
then you do act two and act three then
you take act one and break it down into
sequences there's two to five sequences
in an act
and two to five scenes in a sequence so
you break
the opening act down into say three or
four sequences
you take the first sequence and you've
already got
a chain of events that you've already
figured out from when you figured out
the act
and then you expand upon that a little
more it becomes necessary to think it
through in a little more detail
so you flesh out your outline a little
bit more
and then you do it for the next sequence
and you flesh that out and it's
flesh out not flush out like putting
flesh on bones
and you do that for all the sequences
you develop
a little more detail so now
you've got an outline that has
a reasonable amount of detail to it and
this sequence serves
where is it is tight and dramatic in and
of itself
when the audience watched that sequence
there on the edge of their seat
it's compelling that sequence
serves its function of
what the act is intended to do the act
this unit serves this unit
this is part of this and contributes
toward what the act is trying to do
the act serves the whole because it does
it's part of the mechanism that helps
make the whole story work
so it's a unit inside of a unit inside
of a unit
so then you take the opening sequence
and you divide it down into scenes
and you so
if like this if this is your
opening sequence and there's a chain of
events that constitute that sequence
you're going to say okay this part of it
is the opening scene
so there's still that chain of events
that you'd already figured out that are
constitute that scene
now you're going to take those events
and think it through in a little more
detail you expand upon it a little more
and now you've got final detail so you
have a highly detailed outline
and then you actually write that scene
then you
think through the next scene and expand
upon the detail but you're still
rigorously excluding the unnecessary and
only layering in that which is necessary
to the sequence of events it's all about
the forward progression of events
and that has to do that's particular to
dramatic writing in a novel you really
have a lot more leeway and flow
and but but in something that's being
staged you have to
present a clear forward progression
and you and you want that progression to
move well and not
veer off into unrelated territory
or you don't want to have a dead spot
that's flat dramatically so you lose the
audience
the the basically continuous coherent
compelling dramatic action is the name
of the game
and dramatic action is not car chases
and shootouts
it's not mere action it's a state of
action that you put the audience in
it's all about getting the audience on
the edge of their seat and keeping them
there
they're in a state of action the
audience so continuous
coherent compelling dramatic action the
word compelling is actually redundant
because dramatic action is by definition
compelling
but it just helps people understand it
better so if it's you always want to
have dramatic action
you don't want to ever revert to mere
story you don't want to have parts of
your script go flat dramatically where
it's mere information
you want it to always be actible and
compelling
so this
the scene still is
a causes b which causes c which causes d
and so on it moves
it has a good progression of forward
action with nothing
it's it's only that which is going to be
on stage or on screen with nothing else
it's
it's you continuously strip away the
unnecessary
and the unnecessary kill scripts the
unnecessary you have overwritten
dialogue overwritten descriptions
overwritten scenes scenes that shouldn't
be there
sequences that shouldn't be there
bloated sequences sometimes you have
a whole act that's unnecessary and
what price said was for that matter your
entire script may be unnecessary
which is true way more often than it
should be
those 98 of scripts that don't work are
unnecessary they do not work they
they're landfill they they they can't do
anything with them
so if you
if you are rigorously excluding the
unnecessary
from the big bones of the story to each
act
to each sequence and each scene then you
building the script section by section
and including only that which is
necessary to the forward action of the
story
and the the unnecessary is
rigorously excluded at all times
then your working draft consists of
only that which is necessary every scene
is tight and dramatic
the first three scenes each of which is
titan dramatic make up
the opening sequence which is in and of
itself tight and dramatic
those four sequences each of which are
titan dramatic make up the opening act
which in and of itself is tight and
dramatic and
each of the acts which are titan
dramatic make up the overall story which
is in and of itself tight and dramatic
so
the working draft that you end up with
is gonna
be very much in the ballpark it's gonna
be lean and mean
now that doesn't mean it doesn't need
work it generally needs a lot of work
but it's not a bloated mess
it's a tight thing that's highly
functional and
you can it's basically
the whole premise behind what i teach is
that
and this came straight from price that
you can that if you properly engineer
your script
before you write it then it will
uh save most of the you'll you can use
the same amount of energy to properly
engineer your script before you write it
as you would put into 25 rewrites
so it's better to
structure it properly and then write it
and then build from there
and storytelling
is not always so hard to do but dramatic
dramatizing a story is very tricky
what if a writer says though these are
necessary parts to my story
but outside eyes say no this is
unnecessary unnecessary takes me out of
it
what is missing from this writer that
they think that their
necessary scenes or dialogue is is
actually unnecessary
well well first of all
either they're right or they're not um
either the script works and people want
to make it or it doesn't
if a professional evaluates the script
and says i'm not going to make this
then it doesn't work in that instance
now the next professional they meet
might say
this is brilliant i love it so it's you
know it's
it's flexible in many ways but
it's um
it has to do a lot with
just the craft of a dramatist of
that writer because
they may perceive that something is
necessary to the telling of the story
when actually it only bogs it down
or kills it um
and that happens
a lot if they're overly attached
to the story and
you know how much craft they have
but it's really
the the showrunner i was talking to
she said that she sees so many scripts
that will not work for their
for their show and this is a top this is
one of the top
network shows in the world
and she's the showrunner she's a
showrunner on it
she says she said two things
what they write either is producible
our star will agree to do it
and it will work or it won't
and we're not making it because it's not
what we make
um
she said
that she can tell if somebody can write
really within the first sentence you
know a lot of people say the first five
pages the first page she says yes
first five pages all that but she said i
can tell if they can write or not in the
first sentence
and what often happens is if she
says to this writer this script does not
work and the writer says well that's
just your subjective opinion
she's like they say that to me all the
time but
they're not right it either works or it
doesn't it's not my subjective opinion
it's my professional expertise that i
look at their script for this show
and it does not work and it's not
subjective
so there's
there's professional skill sets and then
there's everybody else's opinion about
what they think is professional writing
and really it's either works or it
doesn't
so people's attachment
to things that they perceive are
necessary
is often mistaken from
either an emotional attachment to the
material
or
a mistaken sense of craft or you know
just they think
they think it helps make the script work
when actually it's
a significant weakness in the material
so they don't know what they don't know
yes or yeah or
they don't know enough and they stick to
their guns
thinking they've got the goods when
like this showrunner would not
even show it to the star of the show
because you know it's like
it has to be this particular thing to go
into our production
slate and it's either that or it's not
it's we write a certain type of show and
it's
and so the writer telling them look
it'll work
it's fresh it's creative it's like
that doesn't matter it's not what we
produce
so it has to do with
what the professional decision makers
are looking for
and what in their experience ruins
the the script
versus the opinion of the writer
and this showrunner said it's not like
these are like
people that never wrote anything these
are rep writers
that are supposed to be professional
writers and they're not even in the
ballpark
so it was
a huge discrepancy between what people
think
works and what the high level decision
makers
will let get past their gate to get into
production
could it be that they weren't properly
told
the exact nature of what they're looking
for i'm just playing the devil's ass no
because the show's been on for years and
it's a
it's a known entity it's like how could
you not know what we
produce here um
but you know is there so many reasons
why people's writing
don't work from
their poor storyteller they don't have
craft as a dramatist
or it's just not right for the entity
they're pitching it to their stuff might
be
astonishingly brilliant but it's just
not right for this show so there's
it's you can't really it's not black and
white at
all there's so many different angles and
approaches
and you know somebody might show up in
town tomorrow with the
script the likes of which no one's ever
seen and it
makes more money than anything ever done
and wins every award and people are like
what the hell was that we didn't we'd
never seen anything like it
we didn't think it would work and it's
brilliant you know you never
anything can go you know but there's
also
rules that
work in certain ways for
what people are looking for so there are
no rules from one point of view and
there are real rules from another point
of view
and all that's real if you invent an
entirely new type of car
it still has to fit on the damn road fit
in the garage
even if it runs on goldfish you know
it's like it's still got a
fit certain aspects of the
infrastructure that's out there
right so you can know music you can be
roger daltrey
and still follow the right pitch and and
cadence and all that i don't not i don't
know much about music but you can still
be unhinged and wild
and now you have tommy and now
you have this like wild sort of creature
and this is what you're talking about
with writing
that you want to see someone that's
that's got fangs and
and claws and yeah even like with
ordinary people there's not a car chase
or a gunfight anywhere within 10 000
miles of that script but it's
so compelling it's absolutely riveting
and it's shocking it's powerful
so it's more about
not blowing more stuff up but going
deeper and not
going down the same rut that everybody
else is going down you know it's just
don't settle for less
be a dynamic storyteller and
you know don't don't make weak
predictable choices that kind of thing
is what i'm talking about
okay you get that at home for free
people go to the movies to see something
fresh and dynamic and world-changing
they
want the people that go to the movies
are hoping
that your movie will
change the way they think for the rest
of their life
people want transformation
they're starving for it they open up
their brain and go do something anything
they want a real experience they want
you to knock their socks off
they don't want to see the same warmed
over murder mystery that they can
see coming 30 miles away and know who
did it
you know 10 minutes into the movie it's
like
i don't have this two hours to watch
crap i
need something powerful
you